I was just checking to see if I had any
orzo in my teeth that was my impression
of a girl you wish you were not able to
be relatable to but you kind of hey guys
my name is grace Helbig if you did not
know now you know your life is different
now I guess I'm making that phrase of
thing today's video is gonna be kind of
short but sweet and I think helpful I
went on my tumblr and asked you guys
what did you want to learn how to do and
a lot of you said that you wanted to
learn how to survive graduating college
or high school and how to be a
functional adult I feel like I've talked
about this in other videos and
interviews so here's my brief rundown of
how you can be a functional adult my
bottom line for success is that you have
to work hard at whatever it is you want
to be successful at you have to gain
experience in that industry or that
field get involved with people or
projects or things that are correlated
to what you want to do network with
people and companies but make sure that
you're enjoying what you're doing and
who you're around because if you aren't
take some time and reevaluate what
you're doing and why you're doing it and
if you want to change your pace create
your own opportunities there are plenty
of ways to do that improvise figure out
something you haven't done yet try
something new because at the end of the
day you only live once that might seem
like a lot all at once but don't worry
if you can't remember what I just said
just remember the acronym Wiener city I
don't know this is a very short video
but surprisingly I worked on coming up
with what words could spell out wiener
City for so long maybe I should
re-evaluate